en este vídeo queremos calcular a que es
igual 833 entre 7 los invito a que pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo por
su cuenta vamos a resolverlo juntos y
quizás se hayan dado cuenta de que esto
es un poquito más difícil de lo que
hemos hecho hasta el momento en este
vídeo les enseñaré un método que quizás
sus padres no hayan visto y que es
bastante divertido se llama división con
cocientes parciales que parece algo
sofisticado pero como les dije antes va
a ser divertido lo primero que voy a
hacer es reescribir esto como 833
dividido entre 7 podemos ver estas como
expresiones iguales y la razón por la
que lo escribimos así es porque en este
formato es más sencillo hacer la
división con cocientes parciales la
forma como funciona la división con
cocientes parciales es que y de nuevo
esta no es la forma con la que sus
padres saben hacer la división es
preguntarse oye cuántas veces cabe 7 en
833 no es necesario saberlo exactamente
solo queremos que sea menor a 833 pues
mi cerebro piensa
y siete centenas son menores a 833 por
lo que 7 cabe en 833 al menos 100 veces
así que lo que hacemos es escribir este
100 aquí arriba y queremos ser
cuidadosos con los valores posicionales
esta columna es la de las centenas esta
columna es la de las decenas y esta
columna es la de las unidades ahora
queremos saber cuánto queda como residuo
que tanto se acerca a 7% lo que hacemos
es multiplicar 100 por 7 lo que da 700 y
luego restamos 700 de 833 para saber
cuánto falta 833 menos 700 es una
centena y 33 por lo que podemos decir
que aún falta 133 cuántas veces cabe 7
en esto nuevamente no tenemos que
calcular esto exactamente por ejemplo
sabemos que 7 por 10 y 70 vamos a usarlo
sabemos que cabe al menos 10 veces vamos
a escribirlo aquí arriba cabe al menos
10 veces y para saber cuánto queda
multiplicamos 10 por 7 lo que da 70
ahora restamos 133 menos 70 nos da 30 es
313 decenas menos siete decenas son seis
decenas por lo que queda 63 7 sin duda
cabe en 63 y hacemos esto hasta que
quede un número que sea menor a 7 aquí
cuántas veces cabe 7 en 63 quizás
recuerden de sus tablas de multiplicar
que 7 por 9 63 por lo que podemos
tenerlo exacto y escribirlo aquí 9 por 7
es 63 y al restar 63 no queda nada y
mientras este número sea menor que 7
sabremos que ya no podemos usar 7 para
dividir el número que queda por lo que
terminamos entonces cuántas veces cabe 7
en 833 pues cupo 100 veces y luego ocupó
otras 10 veces y finalmente cupo nueve
veces más así que lo que hacemos es
sumar todos estos números sumamos 100
más 10 más 9 y que obtenemos 9 unidades
una decena y una centena esto es igual a
119 lo que hicimos fue sumar esto quiero
que quede claro que podemos hacer
divisiones
conscientes parciales y que no les quede
igual a esto y de hecho me parece algo
divertido vamos a hacerlo de otra forma
cuántas veces cada vez 7 en 833 pudimos
decir que quizá cabe 150 veces si
decimos que nuestra estimación ahora es
que cabe 150 veces multiplicamos 150 por
7 cómo lo hacemos
veamos 0 por 7 0 5 por 7 es 35 pongo 5 y
llevo 37 por unos 73 es 10 esto da 1050
por lo que nos pasamos esto es más que
800 33 por lo que 150 es demasiado así
que nos regresamos ahora decimos que
quizá cabe 110 veces vamos a intentarlo
0 por 7 0 1 por 7 7 y 1 por 7 7 110 por
7 770 y como es menor a 833 si nos sirve
veamos qué es lo que queda al restar
queda 3 aquí y 83 decenas menos 77
decenas es igual a 6 decenas
esto nos hace llegar más rápido al
resultado y pueden saber que 7 por 9 a
63 pero imaginemos que no lo saben y que
estiman que cabe 8 veces ponemos un 8
aquí y nos preguntamos cuánto queda 8
por 7 56 lo restamos y 63 56 es igual a
7 por lo que podemos ver que cabe una
vez más lo escribimos aquí 1 por 77 lo
restamos y vemos que no queda residuo
con esto terminamos cuántas veces cabe 7
en 833 18 es 9 más 110 y 119 espero que
encuentren esto interesante y quiero que
piensen en por qué funciona tratamos de
ver cuántas veces cabe sin pasarnos y
luego tratamos de ver cuántas veces cabe
en lo que queda y luego volvemos a
tratar de ver cuántas veces cabe en el
nuevo residuo hasta que lo que quede sea
menor a 7 y ya no quepa una vez más